starting out as a young chef my biggest
influence
was definitely french cuisine and when i
was 23 years of age i was determined to
learn as much as i could
so i set off for paris to work in some
of the most demanding and exacting
kitchens
in the world and my passion and love for
french food
really took hold first up for breakfast
a french patisserie delicacy
madelaine's those shells of a light
sponge flavoured with lemon and poppy
seed
for lunch my take on a french classic
the salad nicoise
with a gutsy caper and anchovy dressing
accompanied by a delicious pear and
creamy goat cheese tartine
tilly and my youngest tilly gets the
taste of french cooking
as we create chicken fricassee
[Music]
so with herbie sauteed potatoes followed
by lavender creme caramel
this is my ultimate french food
breakfast
lunch and dinner my ultimate french
breakfast
isn't complex or flashy it's just simple
elegant
and delicious the secret
to a really good madeline is it's light
fluffy
delicious and it's perfect with the
coffee in the morning
so melt the butter gently next
crack three eggs
[Music]
that was one of the most exciting things
about living in paris there was always
something there in that little pastry
shop that used to live above
gotta incorporate the sugar
and then give that a really good whisk
because it's important to incorporate
some air
now the secret to whisking is a big
beautiful bloon whisk
the bigger the balloon whisk the more
aeration you'll get in the mixture
so the best thing to do is just go from
left to right
and then change hands every 15 or 20
seconds
so your hands never get tired and tilt
the bowl to your advantage as well now
you can see the mixture starting to
aerate
it's almost double in size
[Music]
the more you whisk this the lighter it
becomes
so it starts to almost look like a light
whipped cream
gone is that dark rich egg yolk color
beautiful once the eggs and sugar become
pale creamy and thick
sift in the self-raising flour sieve in
the flour
now i'm giving my madeline's a twist by
adding poppy seeds for a crunch
and lemon for flavor the zest of the
lemon in there
generous on the lemon lime is wonderful
orange zest again beautiful i've even
made
pink grapefruit madeline's with poppy
seed delicious
but lemon for me is the best
pour the melted butter down the side of
the bowl
so it cools down even more and then
combine start mixing that in
it's really important at this stage that
we don't beat
the mixture i want to keep that nice
aerated texture
across the madeleine mix so i'm going to
use a spatula now
and just gently mix my butter in
now give that a good mix and they say
that the longer you make them mix up in
advance
the higher they raise in the oven look
at that
it looks beautiful leave that to sit
there
[Music]
and we'll butter and line our molds
you can make these in little miniature
yorkshire pudding
molds i've even seen madeline's been
cooked in espresso cups so
if you haven't got the traditional
madeline tray
yorkshire pudding trays
now just as good lightly butter
the inside of the tray take a tablespoon
of flour and the secret now is to lie in
the mould
with a flour that stops any chance of
the madeline
sticking tap the sieve
into all the little grooves and this
will ensure that they'll come out
instantly
then all you do then is just stand up
the tray and tap it two or three times
and you'll see the flour
roll out
so there you go the baking sheet
lined beautifully no excess butter and
no excess flour
the beauty of this recipe is that you
can make it the night before and then
simply bake it in the morning
when you're ready to go put the mixture
into a jug to make it really easy to
pour into the tin
give it a little stir so you've got that
nice even distribution of those poppy
seeds
and just gently
lovely fill them up to the top
oh beautiful so much easier pouring this
from a jug because you get
the exact amount in in the oven 180
degrees
do not open that door before 10 minutes
and wait for that wonderful surprise
[Music]
smell amazing now
a little tap on the side of the tray and
should just all pop
out usually
that smell is unique
that nice soft crisp
outside with this lovely fragrant fluffy
center
and the secret of a great madeline as
the french would swear by it
is this lovely little mound on top they
call it the nipple
but that is the confirmation
that is perfect my poppy and lemon
madelaines
are a sophisticated continental start to
the day and take me straight back to
paris
[Music]
coming up i'll be showing you a
fantastic french-inspired lunch and
dinner
[Music]
but first here's a look at some of the
key ingredients you'll need
to add a bit of garlic flair to your
cooking
[Music]
the one ingredient most associated with
french food is garlic
and it's no surprise almost every one of
my french recipes
has it in garlic
is a member of the allium or onion
family and comes in all shapes and sizes
and strengths
pink garlic from lotrek in south west
france is considered the finest with a
strong sweet taste
[Music]
elephant garlic has massive bulbs and a
much milder flavor
but today i'm using a common white type
you get in all the supermarkets
it's a great all-rounder
[Music]
brandy really is the ultimate spirit of
france
it's made from either distilled grapes
or fruit
arminiak from gascony in the south west
is made from wine distilled in oak casks
and is the oldest recorded brandy in
france
cognac's also a wine brandy named after
town in puerto shahar region in the west
where it must be made to be classified
as cognac
calvados is an apple brandy made from
distilled cider and comes from normandy
the french cook with brandy a lot and
tend to ignite or flambe it
to bring amazing depth of flavor to
dishes like the chicken fricker say i'm
serving for dinner
france is justifiably famous for his
cheeses and one of my favorites
is goat's cheese called chev in french
they produce hundreds of types from the
very mild and creamy to the strong and
pungent
and because it's so delicious the french
keep most of it for themselves
and only export a tiny amount
luxurious soft ghost cheese goes
perfectly well with sweet pears
and earthy walnuts in the open sandwich
i'm making for lunch
when i was living in france i got to
know two very distinct traditions
of french food on the one hand there was
the delicious oil cuisine
i cooked all day in the restaurant and
on the other hand there was the food you
ate in people's homes which is a lot
simpler to make
but still absolutely delicious my
ultimate french-inspired lunch
is very light bright and really takes me
back to when i lived in paris
it's my take on the salad nicoise served
with a delicious goat's cheese and pear
tartine
think of the nicoise as an assembly job
of delicious ingredients
brought together with a fantastic
dressing
the secret behind my salad nicoise is in
the dressing
spoon dijon mustard into a pestle and
mortar
some people top the salad with anchovies
and capers but in mine
they're the base to the dressing we're
gonna grind that to a paste
and then get the garlic in there season
well with black pepper
it doesn't need any salt in there
because of the
anchovies add a couple tablespoons of
red wine vinegar
olive oil and lastly flat leaf parsley
to give the dressing freshness against
those deep flavors
it's a thick rich substantial dressing
dressing done
now for the salad ball potatoes green
beans and eggs
from a rolling ball seven and a half to
eight minutes it should keep that nice
yolky creamy texture in the center once
the eggs are ready put them into cold
water to stop them cooking
and this is a great trick to peel them
so much easier peeling eggs when you use
the water
that they've been cooling down in and
the water will seep underneath
all the shell so the whole shell just
gets peeled off with one
beautiful big layer now
beans
nice and crunchy season the beans and
potatoes whilst they're still
warm so they absorb more flavor a little
drizzle
of olive oil salt pepper
and just let them sit there whilst the
potatoes and beans cool down
i'm doing a simple french open sandwich
which is called a tartine
this is delicious first i'm toasting
baguette on the griddle
lightly oil your griddle pan get your
bread
stick it on there take a pear
it goes brilliantly well with goat's
cheese slice the pear
into finger width pieces
that's the color we're looking for that
dark
crispy texture now for the ghost cheese
give it a season it doesn't need salt
because a little fresh goat cheese is
already
quite salty then a handful of crumbled
walnuts
they go under the grill whilst i put the
tuna nice ones together
my secret to assembling a great nicoise
salad is to start in the middle of the
plate
and add ingredients layer by layer
there's one thing i'm always missing the
bottom of salad is dressing
so i like to put it on the plate first
baby gem lettuce is great because it's
robust
and holds that heavy dressing then add
firm waxy salad potatoes and green beans
i like them to have a bit of a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic i'm using a
good quality one in olive oil
which has been drained next baby plum
tomatoes
which have a lovely intense sweet flavor
and then
my eggs that nice dark rich
yolk beautiful
yogurt's still creamy inside
he's a little olive nicoise this will
work just as well with other black
olives
and then the dressing drizzle that round
gently
beautiful that is a nicoise
in heaven now tartine
wow just a smell of those grilled
walnuts
that is beautiful a simple
but very elegant tuna nicoise
with a delicious goat's cheese sandwich
[Music]
wonderful
my vibrant and gutsy nisswa salad with
that incredible anchovy and caper
dressing
served with a pear and goat's cheese
tartine too good to let the french keep
all to themselves
[Music]
in general i think it's pretty fair to
say that whether they're rich or poor
the french are a nation of food
obsessives and
one of the biggest lessons i absorbed
when i was over there was the central
importance
of great ingredients
i'm not the only one in my family who
loves french food
joining me in the kitchen today is my
youngest daughter tilly who adores it
made with fantastic chicken cooked using
a classic but simple french technique
this is my ultimate home-cooked french
dinner
first job my chicken frigge tilly
would you mind helping daddy with the
chicken fricassee please
we're gonna start off with browning
all the chicken off nicely
pan on get that nice and hot what i want
you to do for me first
is to season the chicken with salt and
pepper please
thank you so that's on one side then we
turn the chicken over
so we season it on the other side salt
good girl
and pepper nice now this is almost like
a chicken
stew okay what's that there
[Music]
um time time good girl what's that one
there
that one that's right rosemary and
because this is quite a rustic
french dish we don't need to chop
everything
so you get the garlic and you just bash
it like that
now smell mmm that's right
so that's nice and hot put a tablespoon
of olive oil in there a couple of gloves
one two good girl put the chicken in
it and you lay away
you got that nice and brown i'm getting
good at this you are
skin side down so we got the color on
the skin
now i just want you to cut the mushrooms
in half the belly please
okay these are chestnut mushrooms there
are lots of different kinds
of mushrooms out there there are lots
and lots of different types of mushrooms
which one's your favorite
one of my favorites is the girol
mushroom
i like mushrooms that are a bit bigger
than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle
put pesto and cheese in it and then we
bake them i want you to sprinkle
the pancetta over the chicken please
good girl nice mushrooms
not yet because i'm gonna get some color
on the chicken first
okay and
as that pancetta starts to cook down
it puts a really nice flavor on the
chicken
yeah so we're sort of salting everything
okay all right garlic in please
good girl just throw them in and i want
you to sprinkle the mushrooms on top of
that
good girl and then there's the rosemary
you can get your fingers like that and
you pull it down
you take it all off hold it
put it down good girl so now you've got
the nice little rosemary sprigs
and we do the same with the thyme now
the thyme flour is a little bit smaller
what different flavors do they give so
the thyme is a little bit sweeter
okay and the rosemary a little bit more
savoury
which ones you like i like them both
because they both get a nice smell
don't they so bay leaf in
i'd like you to put that rosemary and
thyme
in there please lovely sprinkle it over
right i'd like you to stand back now
because we're going to flambe this
i do not want to get those little
slippers caught on fire what are the
names
rumpel and judy julia nice
okay great ready yeah
in with a brandy and then just tilt the
pan gently
[Music]
whoa whoa how cool is that magical
beautiful bit like a cauldron all the
cognac
has been flambe so there's no raw
alcohol
anywhere so we've got a really nice deep
rich flavor
i'm gonna add my chicken stock you know
rampo likes that not my slipper ramp or
grandpa the dog ah rumple the dog well
he likes chicken stock
yes when he's a good boy he gets um he
gets it in his um
with his biscuit it's gone in like wow
really quickly
simmer and reduce the stock for around
10 minutes
now we're gonna cook the most amazing
potatoes
soda potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious
start by slicing the potatoes into
finger whipped pieces
then parboil them for five to six
minutes
when you cook something like rosemary or
thyme or basil
does it slowly let off the flavor into
the bottle
very much so in a hot pan
add a tablespoon of goose fat and saute
the potatoes until they turn golden
and add in shallots garlic rosemary and
thyme
that goes in over the top
and that goose fat now is starting to
fry
the potatoes you just leave that sat
there
to complete my ultimate french dinner my
version of a classic
a glorious lavender creme caramel for
dessert
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender
to caster sugar and store you can also
try this trick with vanilla pods and
cinnamon
to bring new subtle flavors to sweets
and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers
and cool now to make a simple custard
gently heat whole milk in a pan until
steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar
until golden and fluffy then gradually
pour the hot milk
into the mix whisking continuously until
the custard is smooth
and creamy to set cook in a water bath
or bamboo
a good tip is to line a roasting tin
with a cloth to stop the ramekins
jiggling around pour your custard
then boiling water around the ramekins
until halfway
up the sides then cook in a preheated
oven for around 30 minutes
until set cool in the fridge then when
you're ready to serve
dip the ramekins in hot water to loosen
the creme caramel
the ebola lavender clean caramel
[Music]
look at that chicken now so i'm just
gonna
turn the gas right down and put the lid
on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can net out some stuff so i can let
out some steam that's right
now what i'd like to do is to chop daddy
some parsley crunch it up nicely
tuck your fingers in take your time
[Music]
you could almost be french
sprinkle that on there good girl
nice messy buckle
nice now potatoes
i can tell jack's gonna love this is he
looks the nest doesn't it smells
delicious look at that
i could smell that even before you took
the lid off let's get on my darling
good job by the way thank you i can't
wait for the others to try it i hope
they
love it this is my ultimate french
dinner
chicken fricassee with sensational
herbie sauteed potatoes
and lavender creme caramel meg jack
mum and holly oh so nice doesn't it
now daddy who's the one that burnt the
garlic
how could you dad
tilly trust you to find that jack
potatoes
i thought you'd like these ones oh no
way she's on a roll
potatoes burnt garlic
bon appetit and look out for the burnt
garlic it was supposed to be crispy i
thought you would have known the
difference between crispy
and burnt you know what i think your
daughter might take
after you hi sous chef cheers
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck
you